Let's go ahead and get me done.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Okay, so we have officially broken out of this very annoying trading range, but
this is again, guys, like, you know how many people get stuck here, like trying
to trade every, every single day, like there was, since this range began.
There had been one, two, three, four, five, six, six, full trading days, and we
executed, what's this?
That's just going to break even here, execute on one trade, that was very
profitable, second trade, break even.
Yeah, second trade, break even, third trade, very profitable, three trades in
what many people would call horrible, choppy, ridiculous price action.
Three, we very select trade setups, two winners, huge winners, and one break
even with great risk management, great trade management.
This is like, was it eight, this was like, I don't know, like, seven, like 15%
gain in three trades, probably a bit more across this type of price action.
Everyone complains, oh, the markets, oh, the ranges, oh, Trump, all this, all
that, it's like, no, it was always, it was always your, you from the beginning.
You can trade that, maybe not.
What's that, first day, the first of May?
We have ISM at 10.
Yeah, that's tradable though, for sure.
Probably use this.
I'm really looking at doors to the same version of how you got.
15, maybe the body.
Again, just want to find what about the risk reward as well, that's another
thing we didn't think about.
It's a 4.5 risk reward.
Just straight flat out, 1 to 5.
Initial balance, 1%.
Just looking for a 1 to 5.
Tag, no news.
Can we sync timeframe please?
Let's break even.
Lovely price action.
Okay, did we journal that trade?
I would rather consider that as a New York sweep, London.
But then I'll ask you in the day.
Technically.
Okay.
Honestly, there's anything that I've already realized that this structure flow
is not going to make any difference as a variable.
I'm not sure about the trend, but I also don't think so.
Point of interest maybe.
For certain setups, that will help, I think.
The trend, I don't think that's going to help.
Execution window.
I'm not sure about that one.
It's going to be an FP.
It's going to be an inflation rate.
I don't like how shallow that is as a sweep of liquidity.
Not a huge fan because I just don't like where the star pluses and don't think
that's a deep enough liquidation, but maybe I'm completely wrong.
It could also argue that we could trade down to this low as well.
This is the actual theoretical swing low is here.
But if price is going to trade lower, it's going to almost definitely trade
below this low.
Monday, the 5th of May, Web ISM.
It's difficult to expect price to tag that level.
Honestly, at this point, not even sure if it's worth keeping the order on.
That's five.
Yeah, you did as well as it is.
Not actually surprised.
Web ISM.
Let's have a little luck, shall we?
There could be a shift.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Yeah, price is bullish, looking for longs.
Not a huge fan of price action in general, but just plain.
So if there are equal highs up there, I don't know, just plain the edge.
Just playing the edge.
Still technically bullish.
So there.
I'm not going to get a trade off the back of that.
Probably not going to get a trade in New York session.
I wouldn't trade that.
No, this is a difficult one because this is where my own personal discretion
would come in as you guys already know.
I'm never going to use edge session high as a swing structure unless we
continue visibly trading lower.
So I guess in this scenario, I'll probably just do nothing.
I just didn't really move anyway.
Let's see.
And there we go, lower.
That unsurprising to me.
I don't like using edge session to prefer this range here.
But out of our action.
So, and yeah, 12 of May.
The market just decided to go crazy.
I appreciate all my business price action.
I do remember this price action, of course.
Game purely objective.
This becomes the point of interest.
That becomes entry, right?
No.
This technically becomes discretionary because the external is aligned with the
internal.
No, the M1 is bearish from here.
So it ends up becoming discretion.
Yeah.
Pretty much that entire leg is efficient pricing.
We'll just go from this M5 buy candle.
There's no way that this would be 13 pip stop in 2024 or 2023 is even crazier.
Like as in 2023, you had such small stops.
It's a 5 pip.
It's a tag.
That would be break even pretty much.
Although that's unmetigated.
And then that would be press out.
And still doesn't get five hard, does it?
Okay, we'll come back.
Again, decided not to go to break even off the basis that this leg specifically
is still unmetigated.
And so my stops above here end up reducing it from a 1% loss to a 0.6% loss.
So still lost reduction, still lost mitigation, but the management could have
cost me here.
But then again, maybe not because price doesn't even take profit yet, and it'll
be back to breaking right now.
So we'll see.
But we have to move on.
And in moving on, it's also discretionary.
Let's come in here.
So everything is aligned, but it's still discretionary.
And large can kind of be defined as like literally the entire price leg of the
15 minute, which is what it is like nine times out of 10, or extremely,
extremely large.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Hold on a second, I don't know how that happened.
And I don't know if I didn't just decided not to remove the order or something,
let me see what's going on here.
How we already tapped into the position I don't understand.
I literally said if you remember, we're going to use this is what the line is
drew here as you can already see the line.
We're going to use this M5 by, I don't know why the order was lower, but this
is what the actual was.
You were, I don't know what just happened, but you'll be able to see it as you
were just watching it.
That was supposed to be the set up, and it's 950.
I don't know, maybe attacked because that's not a tag.
And the level of price didn't get attacked, so it's technically not a trade.
I don't know why it was, I had it entered at the change of character for some
reason.
I don't know if maybe you would have seen it better than I did, but
yeah, I just realized that because I was looking at the execution and I
realized that the execution didn't make sense.
At the point by which I haven't been tagged in by 10am, the limit becomes
removed.
It wasn't really a marathon, actually that big of deal ended up actually
following my rules ends up as no trade.
Follow my rules and not following them ended up like 0.6%.
It doesn't break the bank, but the point is I want to get the day accurate.
But this here.
Okay, that means that all this M1 becomes aligned.
Which means that technically becomes Frankfurt Sweep London continuation.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
That is a tag mitigation.
At least if not honestly break human.
Yeah, that's fine.
Objectively based on all the other time frames, I was really looking at that as
just a genuine, pure break human.
But I don't mind.
Either way ends up going from like a 1% to a 0.2%.
Effect win rate, but win rate alone is irrelevant.
It also reduces the average losing value of a trade.
Which again is irrelevant in and of itself.
Let's see, this is a frank sweep, uh, no this day.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Good measurements.
Let me have a look at this.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
If I'm trading this live, I haven't taken any partials.
I stopped to a break even.
That's at 8am.
Either I want to close right now.
This is back testing, so I can get away with it.
Not getting spread and slippage and stuff like that.
But in an environment where I haven't taken any partials, we're very close to
break even.
All right, this is the nuance.
Like if I'm in a position, I'm out in the position here, for example.
And I'm here.
My first partial is here.
My full profit is down here.
And there's about to be news that drops and my stops are at break even.
And I haven't taken any partials.
I'm at break even and news is in here.
That's probably where you want to be looking at closing your trade.
Right?
In a different position, different scenario.
Let's say I'm in here, for example, right?
And I've already taken partials.
And my stops are at break even.
And my final type of is down here.
And I'm kind of just like somewhere in here and news is about to be released.
I wouldn't really worry about it.
We're not that close to break even.
News is the worst case going to bring you up here.
And then you might get tagged at break even then it's like fine.
Or it could just move in your favor, which is like bonus.
So I don't mind holding through news occasionally.
But when this is the context of you have all this by side liquidity, you stop
through a break even.
You're already close to here and you haven't taken partials, which are all the
way down here.
I would even close the trade.
Well, yeah, probably close the trade or at least close like close do the math.
For example, like right now prices run in, let's say one hour.
So what you want to do is you just want to close like 75% of the trade and
leave that 25% running.
So if you get slipped by a little bit, the difference is going to be somewhere
in the region
of break even or small profit.
If you want to keep it, if you're running, that's going to be your
responsibility.
You're going to have to do that in the real in real time.
Because we're in breaking because we are in back testing, it doesn't really
matter.
I can just leave it and I'm not going to get slipped.
But in the real market, you may get slipped.
For example, like that.
Like, trust me, when I tell you, you don't want to have your stop loss at break
even.
At that moment.
When you're so close already, that's the thing that people don't understand.
It's like, it's contextual.
If your entry is here, right?
And news is coming out on prices here.
Well, all of a sudden you're at a far greater risk of losing money to slippage
than if your stop loss was here.
And prices here, right?
Because if price moves 30 pips upwards, you're going to get that here.
I mean, 30 pips upwards here, you might get that, right?
These are the things, they're just, it's obvious, of course, but you need to
make sure that you're aware of that and factor in that.
In this scenario, I can leave my stop at break even because I'm not going to
get slipped in back testing.
But in the real market, I can't do that.
So, be aware of that.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
And we shift bullish.
Probably not going to get up to you after that.
Okay.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Difficult price action.
Way better, apologies.
I wasn't even thinking about why I was doing it.
We're a structure.
We're bullish.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
That's our structure.
That's our structural law.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
As I am one structure.
We just shifted bearish on the M1 so we can't trade this.
So it's fine.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Yeah.
Wednesday, 14th of May, no news.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Oop.
We're bearish.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
None of that is a structure.
Even if that was the change of character.
That pulls back and shoots here.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
So that's it.
Yeah, probably used that.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Just going to buy this orange value gap here.
15th.
We have PPI and retail sales 8.30.
Oh, that's already happened.
Notice that in 2025's market.
Retail sales, PPI, these type of things, they're far less impactful
than they were in 2024.
Probably because of the surge of volume.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Oh, that's only a one to three.
Still looking for shorts, yeah.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
We are getting a liquidity build up here, but.
They didn't go to New York.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Okay.
And that's the shift bullish.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Probably not going to get an opportunity.
Looking for lungs.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Okay, that would be.
Probably have to go to internal structure if you wanted to trade it.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Doesn't technically meet the rules, although not only would I trade this, but I
did trade this out.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Oh, wait.
There's no real other way to trade it, but we'll leave it.
I would take it 100 times out, 100 in the real market, but we'll leave it.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
They're all liquidations.
Wait a minute, how do you know that's the structure?
You don't because the structure a minute ago.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
That's a work.
It's not a trade all.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
My bad, apologies if you're wondering why.
It's very simple.
M1 structure is bearish until this high is broken.
Nope.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Which means they're still bearish.
And now we are confirmed change of character as well.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Now we're technically bullish.
It's technically two candles which is a little bit frustrating, of course.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Still bullish.
Need a pullback and continuation.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
27.
I want to make sure we don't have any news at five exactly.
We don't.
We have job of goods, but I mean honestly.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
I'm not a huge fan of the huge moves.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, yeah, for a low risk reward to be honest with you.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
It's only a wick, but honestly, let's see.
It's got a head stops.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Technically calm, but I would move my stop loss right now.
Nice.
We do have news here though.
We have durable goods, which so far hasn't really been having an impact.
But see if that hypothesis remains.
Yeah, that's like practically nothing.
CS5R.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
And it's a break even.
Good management.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Still bullish.
Honestly.
It's a potential price to trade from this level and give reaction, but.
I would probably have stopped to break even if price was this high up in the
price like.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
That's a mitigation.
That's an expansion.
It definitely gets break even after that.
That's fine.
That's good management.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Well, we have very much bearish.